you saw what happened with James Corden
recently did you hear about that or no
he's going to this one restaurant did
you see how the Balcones are did you see
this or no can you put this up so people
can see it so uh James uh James Corden
goes to this restaurant James Corden
goes to this restaurant and thank you
yeah you got it James Corden goes to
this restaurant and he starts chewing
out the actor the waitress and a waiter
twice
so the owner in the restaurant you
didn't hear about this no post the
Instagram post of what the owner said
put that up and let's read that first
the first one
before he goes to the second one it's
Classic this is why sometimes
stars get a bad reputation because of
stories like this that gets revealed and
people finally say you know what I just
I don't want to deal with this Hollywood
star he's a headache I got pulled I
pulled him over one time he was so rude
to me as a cop you can't find it oh my
God you gotta find to see it okay right
there right there's a click on that one
and then go to the first one he posted
because it's a couple of them
that's the owner of the restaurant keep
going down let's just see if he removed
it or not okay first one right there
click on that zoom in
did this sermon restaurant okay he
removed it
give me give me just a minute yeah he
has another one anyway so he says to him
um
let me find it here you have to see this
one James Corden restaurant owner
so James corden's in trouble right now
oh my but you should have seen what
happens to the point where no he's not
in big trouble at all there's there's
nothing about it that is
uh uh uh here you go I just found it I'm
going to send it to you I'm gonna send
it to you and I'm gonna read it
so he goes to this restaurant and he's
having dinner and it's a very very
famous restaurant in New York okay
so the owner comes out and he posts he
says James Gordon is a hugely gift to
comedian but a tiny creaking of a man
and the most abusive customer to my
baltazar services since the restaurant
opened 25 years ago I don't often 66 a
customer but today I'd 66th Gordon it
did not make me laugh here are two
example of the funny man treatment of my
staff manager report number one and June
James Corden was here on table 61. he's
been very detailed although this
diabolical uh it happens very
occasionally in all restaurants after
eating his main course Gordon showed the
hair to Balthazar manager G who was very
apologetic Gordon was extremely nasty to
G and said get us another round of
drinks this second and also take care of
all of our drinks so far this way I
write any nasty reviews to Yelp or
anything like that he says manners
report number two James Corden wants
that Balthazar with his wife on October
9th for brunch she asked for a table
outside brunch uh maitre d Ali Walters
took the party to table 301 Mr Gordon's
wife ordered a an egg yolk omelet with
uh cheese and a salad a few minutes
later they received the food James
called their server and told her that
there was a little bit of egg white
mixed with egg yolk and informed the
floor manager the kitchen remade the
dish but unfortunately send it to home
fries instead of uh send it with home
fries instead of salad that's when James
Corden began yelling like crazy to the
server you don't do your job you don't
do your job maybe I should go into the
kitchen and cook The Omelette myself and
then MK the waitress was very apologetic
and brought Gordon over the table uh he
returned the dish and after that
everything was fine he gave them promo
champagne glass to smooth things out and
Gordon was pleasant to him but nasty to
the server who was shaken by it but
professional that she admitted she
decided to continue anyways so the owner
post this who owns this restaurant yeah
two days later
he posts another one and he gets a call
from Gordon and Corden calls him very
apologetic he says I have to post this
now he called he was very apologetic he
was sincere about it and I have decided
to remove and his suspension and he can
come back to the restaurant and
apparently yesterday Gordon on his Late
Show addressed this
in a very interesting way he addressed
this yesterday so
there's a reason why sometimes New York
restaurant feels very really sorry for
James James Gordon after exposing him uh
and now he's feeling sorry about it
because everyone's talking about this
but you hear these types of stories how
Hollywood star sometimes go places and
they feel like they're entitled that's
the biggest thing the feeling
entitlement so apparently uh with you
and by the way that whole story you were
talking about how you would go places
and people were looking and one day
you're like screw it I want to be this
person when he came out of the camp it's
almost like Kobe Bryant when he was
being judged constantly and I'm not
making a comparison to the late Kobe
Bryant in basketball it's the mindset if
you think I'm evil I'm gonna be evil if
you think I am this bad guy guess what
I'm going to play this role and I'm
going to play naturally I'm going to
give it to you black mamba so
psychologically it almost forces you to
play that cards very hard uh to you know
want to play a different role then you
kind of also almost want to retaliate
because you're being judged for no
reason I can't see that happening so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]